This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
这是一个iHeart播客。保证真人。嘿，大家好，你们好吗？欢迎收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖恩斯（Kear Games）为你带来的《艰难一课》（Learn the Hard Way）。这个空间聚焦于黑人男性的经历，进行在其他任何地方都绝不安全的坦诚对话，而你正在与一位深谙此道的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人身披一副盔甲。它向世界发出信号：你可不是好惹的。但这并不意味着只要你有这个能力，就必须这样做，听听并学习。
the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Mancini.
以艰难的方式，在AHA电台应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。2023年，《单身汉》（Bachelor）明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控生下了双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是一场骗局。你曾两次篡改这份特定的检测报告，对吗？我篡改过一次检测。这动用了大批互联网侦探，才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两名经历过同样事情的男士：格雷格·吉莱斯皮（Greg Gillespie）和迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Mancini）。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
我当时惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《受困之爱》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于要承担后果了。在iHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《受困之爱》播客。2%。这就是当旁边有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人所占的比例。
I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA percent on the IHeartRadio app, Apple podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say
我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养心理韧性、体能和构建适应力的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你最终会迎来一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的自己。收听《2%》。也就是在iHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方搜索TWA percent。当一群女性发现她们约会过的竟是同一个声名狼藉的骗子时，她们决定自己动手。我发誓。我要成为他最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说
that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s, and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Before we get into the episode, I wanted to let you guys know that we now have a YouTube channel.
相信你的闺蜜。在iHeart radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《相信闺蜜，相信我，宝贝》（Trust the Girlfriends. Trust me, babe）。大家好，欢迎回到《你二十岁的心理学》（The psychology of your 20s），这是一个与大家一起探讨我们二十岁时面临的重大生活改变与转型，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么的播客。大家好。在进入本期节目之前，我想告诉大家，我们现在有了一个YouTube频道。
You guys have been asking for video episodes and video versions of the podcast for so long, we finally were able to make it happen. We've been doing it for a couple of months now. So if you like watching your podcast, if you want to see behind the scenes, if you want to see some more live and in your face recordings, that is where you should go. It's just the psychology of your 20s on YouTube. I'd really appreciate
大家一直以来都在要求视频版的播客和视频内容的节目，我们终于把它做成了。我们已经做几个月了。所以，如果你喜欢看播客，如果你想看到幕后花絮，如果你想看到更多面对面的现场录制，那这就是你应该去的地方。在YouTube上搜索“the psychology of your 20s”即可。我真的非常感谢
you quickly jumping over there and subscribing because it's a new platform for me. It's a new thing that I am trying out. But I hope you enjoy it. I hope you love it. Without further ado, let's get into the episode. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. Today, we are talking about failure, but not the bad parts about failure, not even why failure necessarily sucks or feels terrible, but rather, we're doing a full 180 mindset shift on this. We're going to talk about the gift of failure and how falling in love with failure, maybe even deliberately running towards
大家能快快过去点个订阅，因为这对我是个全新的平台。这是我正在尝试的新事物。但我希望你们会喜欢它。希望你们能爱上它。闲话少说，让我们进入本期节目。大家好。欢迎回到本节目。欢迎回到播客。新听友，老听友，无论你身处世界的哪个角落。非常高兴你能回来收听我们的又一期节目，当然，我们今天要剖析的是二十岁的心理学。今天，我们要谈论的是失败，但不是失败中糟糕的部分，甚至不是失败必然糟糕或感觉糟糕的原因，而是我们要对这个话题做一个180度的大转弯。我们要谈论的是失败带来的馈赠，以及爱上失败，甚至刻意奔向
it will unlock your dream life and so much of what you desire for yourself faster than probably any other method out there. Now, this episode, this is going to sound so strange, but it was weirdly inspired by Victoria Beckham, i.e. Posh Spice. Stay with me here. I know this feels very off brand for me, but I watched her documentary on Netflix the other day where she describes basically the highs and lows of her career. I posted it on my story and so many of you responded and it weirdly brought up so many reflections for me on failure. Now obviously she is a celebrity. She had a lot of control over the narrative that was portrayed in that documentary. But I think my own relationship to failure has changed so much recently that everything she was talking about kind of resonated on a
它，将如何比市面上的任何其他方法更快地开启你的梦想生活，实现你对自己的诸多渴望。现在，本期节目听起来可能会非常奇怪，但它的灵感居然来自维多利亚·贝克汉姆（Victoria Beckham），也就是“辣妹”Posh Spice。请听我解释。我知道这与我的风格大相径庭，但前几天我在Netflix上看了她的纪录片，片中她讲述了自己职业生涯的高潮与低谷。我把它发到了我的快拍上，你们很多人都进行了回复，这奇迹般地引发了我对失败的许多反思。当然，她是个名人。在那部纪录片中，她对所呈现的叙事有着很大的掌控力。但我觉得，我最近对失败的看法改变了太多，以至于她谈论的一切都在某种
new level. And for the first time in my life, I feel more positive about it than negative. My whole life isn't focused on avoiding failure anymore. And it definitely was when I was younger. I was so obsessed with making sure every single step, every single decision was the perfect decision, never falling short of my expectations. But strangely, you know, this is the year that I have failed more than I ever have before and maybe I'll talk about it a little bit further down the line when some of the dust has kind of settled but I have failed more this year than any other year in my life and I have never felt more confident and certain in what I'm doing almost because of that. So let's talk about it today. What is the freedom that you can find in failure,
全新的层面上引起了我的共鸣。我生命中第一次对它感到更多的是积极而非消极。我的整个生活不再专注于避免失败了，而我年轻时绝对是这样的。我曾经极其执着于确保每一步、每一个决定都是完美的决定，绝不低于我的期望。但奇怪的是，你知道，今年是我失败最多的一年，也许以后当尘埃落定后我会再详细谈谈，但我今年的失败比我生命中任何一年都多，而我却从未像现在这样对自己在做的事情感到如此自信和确定，几乎正是因为这个原因。所以我们今天就来聊聊这个。你能在失败中找到什么样的自由，
especially in your 20s in the so-called failure decade? Why is it that failure is one of the singular things that all successful people have in common, no matter what industry they're in across time, what is it about those people that approach failure differently to the rest of us? And from that, how can we cultivate a mindset that sees this as us actually getting closer to what we want rather than further away? That's going to sound strange, given how we've been taught to think about this experience, but I promise it will make more sense as the episode goes on. I am so into talking about this topic at the moment in my own life and with my friends. So I hope you can kind of feel that energy like coming off me right now.
特别是在你的二十岁，这个所谓的失败十年里？为什么失败是所有成功人士共同具备的独一无二的特质之一，无论他们属于哪个行业、历经哪个时代，那些以不同方式对待失败的人到底有什么特别之处？由此，我们该如何培养一种心态，将此视为我们实际上离想要的东西更近了，而不是更远了？听起来可能很奇怪，考虑到我们一直以来被教导如何看待这种经历，但我保证随着节目的深入，这会更有道理。我目前非常热衷于在自己的生活中以及和朋友们谈论这个话题。所以我希望你们能感受到我此刻散发出的那种能量。
I'm so excited to get into it. Without further ado, let's talk about why we need to fall in love and how we can fall in love with failure. Stay with us. So let's start with a very simple question. Why do we fear failure? I say simple, but there are many, many layers to this conundrum, starting with the most basic explanation, which is that we fear failure because it feels bad. Simple as that. It injures our
我太兴奋想要切入正题了。闲话少说，让我们来谈谈为什么我们需要爱上失败，以及我们如何才能爱上失败。请继续收听。那么让我们从一个非常简单的问题开始。我们为什么害怕失败？我说得简单，但这个谜题有很多很多的层次，首先是最基本的解释，那就是我们害怕失败是因为它感觉很糟糕。就这么简单。它会伤害我们的
ego. It's embarrassing. That creates, you know, emotional, psychological and social pain within us. Really, what it's based in is self-worth and how much we implicitly tie self-worth to external achievement and the progress, the visible progress we make towards our goals. When we view it, ourselves as creatures of output and I guess also creatures of performance whose value is derived from what we do rather than who we are inherently. Anytime we come up short of what we expect of ourselves or what others expect from us, it strikes really deep, deep into our sense of character. And it also attaches to things like our discipline, our intelligence, our innate talent,
自我。这很尴尬。这会在我们内心产生（你知道的）情感、心理和社会痛苦。实际上，它的根源在于自我价值感，以及我们将自我价值与外部成就以及我们在实现目标的道路上取得的可见进展紧密捆绑在一起的程度。当我们把自己视为产出创造者，我想也是表现创造者时，我们的价值源于我们做了什么，而不是我们本质上是谁。每当我们的表现达不到对自己的期望或他人对我们的期望时，它就会深深地、重重地击中我们的性格感。而且它还与我们的自律、智力、天赋相关，
our ability to work out, our creativity, strength, all of those things are deeply personal self-assessments and deeply personal attributes. So when we feel like because we have failed, it's because we lack those things or there is some deficiency in those things. That is deeply painful and it's mainly first and foremost to do without ego. Now, of course, this didn't come from nowhere. if you have ever been around children recently, specifically young kids, you will notice they don't really concern themselves with whether what they're doing is good or comparatively better than anyone else or up to their own standards. All they want to do is explore and learn and appreciate and love. And then at some stage, this pressure gets added onto them, onto us.
我们的锻炼能力、创造力、力量，所有这些都是非常私人的自我评估和非常私人的特质。所以当我们觉得因为失败了，就代表我们缺乏这些东西，或者在这些方面存在某种缺陷。那是极其痛苦的，而且主要首先与我们的自我有关。当然，这并非凭空出现。如果你最近一直在小孩子身边，尤其是年幼的孩子，你会发现他们根本不关心自己做的事情是否优秀，是否比别人更好，或者是否符合他们自己的标准。他们只想探索、学习、欣赏和热爱。然后在某个阶段，这种压力被强加到了他们身上，强加到了我们身上。
Now, of course, you know, kids make mistakes, but all their mistakes are like, hey, when I jump off the playground, I will break my arm. I'm not going to jump off the playground. Or when I hit someone, I will be scolded. These are all lessons and, you know, mistakes that hopefully shape them into good and safe people. When there is an academic setting, when they enter a schooling setting, that's when like this idea of failure that we know now actually begins to take hold. the idea of like, there is a way I should perform. There is something I should be able to do or obtain. People have expectations for me to be able to do this. And so when I don't, that means I am not good enough. That means I have failed.
当然，你知道，小孩子们会犯错，但他们所有的错误都类似于：“嘿，如果我从游乐场跳下去，我会骨折。我可不从游乐场跳下去。”或者“如果我打别人，我会挨骂。”这些都是教训，你知道的，这些错误有望将他们塑造成为优秀且安全的人。当存在学术环境时，当他们进入学校环境时，我们现在所知道的这种“失败”的概念才真正开始扎根。类似于：我应该有一种表现方式。我应该能够做到或获得某些东西。人们对我有期望，期望我能够做到这一点。所以当我做不到时，就意味着我不够好。这就意味着我失败了。
It should come as no surprise that this situation, this setting, combined with a critical childhood environment, specifically parents who have high standards for us and make that known, this really exacerbates the situation and this feeling or fear of failure. You know, our parents may just want better for us. We can give them the benefit of the doubt in these situations and say, you know, they just thought that what they were doing was correct. But in the end, studies on critical parenting have found the long-term effects of this
这种情况、这种环境，再加上批判性的童年环境（特别是那些对我们抱有高标准并明确表达出来的父母），毫无疑问会加剧这种状况以及这种对失败的感觉或恐惧。你知道，我们的父母可能只是希望我们过得更好。在这些情况下，我们可以对他们抱有善意，并说，你知道，他们只是认为他们所做的是对的。但最终，关于批判性育儿的研究发现，其长期的影响
are actually probably the reverse of what our parents expected. It's perfectionism. It's a crippling desire to succeed. but that actually creates greater procrastination, greater inflexibility, incapable high standards that make failure feel like such an emotional burden that the only way to avoid it is to not even try. Over time as well, I feel like their voice, the voice of the critical parent, begins to mold with our own inner critic's voice as well.
实际上可能与我们父母的期望相反。它是完美主义。是一种对成功的瘫痪般的渴望。但这实际上造成了更严重的拖延、更大的死板，以及高得无法实现的标准，这些标准让失败变成了一种巨大的情感负担，以至于避免失败的唯一方法就是甚至不去尝试。随着时间的推移，我也觉得他们的声音，也就是批判型父母的声音，开始与我们内心批评者的声音融为一体。
And so it's almost impossible to indistinguish them. Like when we feel like we have failed, all we hear is their voice in our head saying, try harder. That's not good enough. That doesn't meet my standards. I'm disappointed in you. These experiences, and there's so many others that are like this, but these experiences create learned associations where failure feels unsafe.
所以几乎不可能把它们区分开来。就像当我们觉得自己失败时，我们听到脑海里全是他们的声音在说：“再努力一点。那样还不够好。那不符合我的标准。我对你很失望。”这些经历，还有许多其他类似经历，创造了习得性联想，让失败感觉很不安全。
Psychologically, our brains code it as a threat. activating that same kind of panicked response we would have for anything that's terrifying or fearful or threatening. So really what it is is that our sense of failure comes from social expectation and these rules around what success is and isn't. And those rules are the ones that we have inherited from generations and generations before us. And these rules are based on this hierarchy for what is successful and what is not. Often success means having more, being the best, obtaining more, being number one, this elevated status. What's interesting is that, again, that is completely socially conditioned and subjective. You know, animals don't agonize over their failures. Our perception of whether
从心理学上讲，我们的大脑将其编码为一种威胁。激活了那种我们面对任何可怕、恐惧或威胁性的事情时都会产生的惊慌失措的反应。所以，实际上我们的失败感来自于社会期望以及围绕成功与否的这些规则。而这些规则是我们从前人那里继承下来的。这些规则基于一种关于什么是成功、什么不是成功的等级制度。通常，成功意味着拥有更多、成为最好、获得更多、成为第一，这种崇高的地位。有趣的是，再次说明，这完全是社会条件反射和主观的。你知道，动物们不会为自己的失败感到痛苦。我们对是否
we've failed or been successful as well, like really changes based on what we've been told about the task or told about the thing that we're doing or about certain performance metrics. Take for example, this is the example actually I used with a friend the other day, the 200 meter sprint at the Olympics. Now, if you want to win gold, if you want to be a so-called success at that sport, being the fastest would make you a winner. Being the slowest would make you think of yourself as a failure. But imagine if the actual task of the 200 meters was to run backwards,
失败或成功的感知，也是根据我们被告知的任务、被告知我们正在做的事情或关于某些绩效指标的信息而发生极大变化的。以这个为例，其实这是我前几天和一个朋友举的例子，奥运会200米短跑。现在，如果你想赢得金牌，如果你想成为该运动所谓的成功者，成为跑得最快的人就会让你成为赢家。跑得最慢会让你觉得自己是个失败者。但想象一下，如果200米的实际任务是倒着跑，
or was to cartwheel the whole thing. The fastest person would then be seen as a failure because the structure of the task has changed, not because of anything that's wrong with them. They are still the fastest, that just doesn't matter. This is the same with life sometimes. You know, there is a big focus, again, on accumulating, on being the best, on getting ahead.
或者全程都在做侧手翻。跑得最快的人就会被视为失败者，因为任务的结构改变了，而不是因为他们本身有什么问题。他们仍然是最快的，只是这不重要了。有时生活也是如此。你知道，人们非常关注积累、成为最好、出人头地。
But if our performance metrics for the task of life was instead to enjoy ourselves, to love more, to experience more, to try and to fail and to learn, all, like this whole hierarchy, this all concept of what makes someone a success and what makes someone a failure would change because it is socially conditioned. I think aside from that, on a more personal level, you know, sometimes we fear failure because we actually just don't like the idea of being seen, of being in the spotlight. for seemingly the wrong reasons.
但如果我们的人生任务的绩效指标变成了享受当下、去爱更多、体验更多、去尝试、去失败并去学习，那么所有，就像整个等级制度、关于什么让人成功什么让人失败的整个概念都会改变，因为它是社会制约的。我想除此之外，在更个人的层面上，你知道，有时我们害怕失败是因为我们实际上根本不喜欢被关注、处于聚光灯下的感觉。似乎是因为错误的原因。
You don't actually have a fear of failing. You fear failing in public. I think this is why we resonate a lot with those videos that are like, I disappeared for a year and I came back a whole new person. Like people love those videos. And I saw someone say it's because the disappearing part allows us to conceal the occasional ugliness of trying and failing. The disappearing part means that we don't have to see all the times that someone did not
你其实并不是害怕失败。你是害怕在公众面前失败。我想这就是为什么我们对那些类似于“我消失了一年，回来后焕然一新”的视频产生强烈共鸣的原因。人们非常喜欢那些视频。我看到有人说这是因为消失的部分让我们得以掩盖尝试和失败时偶尔呈现的丑陋。消失的部分意味着我们不必看到别人没有达到
meet their own expectations or felt like they had fallen behind. Our fear of being perceived is where this comes from. Also on another non-social level, sometimes it's just the cost of failure that scares us. Now, of course, that's the financial cost. It's also the time cost, the energy costs, the effort costs, the opportunity cost that we could have put elsewhere. When we put a lot into something and it doesn't go our way, it feels like a waste. And our natural human loss aversion, this instinct we have, it cringes at that feeling.
自己期望或感觉自己落后的所有时刻。我们对被审视的恐惧正是源于此。此外，在另一个非社会的层面上，有时仅仅是失败的代价让我们感到害怕。当然，这是金钱成本。这也是时间成本、精力成本、努力成本、我们可以投入到别处的机会成本。当我们对某事投入巨大却没有得到想要的结果时，这感觉就像是一种浪费。而我们人类天生的损失厌恶，即我们拥有的这种本能，会对那种感觉退避三舍。
You know, if we strip away all the social pressure, the disappointment, the comparison, sometimes we just really want something for ourselves and we bet everything we have on it and it doesn't happen. And that lack of a payout is what can be devastating. And this is where the relationship between privilege and failure is so important to discuss. The cost of failure, it's going to differ for different people and that will change the psychological relationship that we have with it. From a psychological standpoint, our willingness to take risks is influenced by something that we call perceived safety.
你知道，如果我们剥离掉所有的社会压力、失望、比较，有时我们只是真的为自己想要某样东西，我们把所有的一切都押在它上面，而它却没有发生。而那种缺乏回报的感觉可能是毁灭性的。这就是特权与失败之间的关系如此重要，值得探讨的原因。失败的代价对不同的人是不同的，这会改变我们与它之间的心理关系。从心理学的角度来看，我们承担风险的意愿受到一种我们称之为感知安全感的事物的支配。
if we grow up with financial or social privilege, access to education, access to second chances, supportive networks, family wealth, or simply the reassurance that you can recover, your brain will learn that failure is survivable. You can afford to see it as a learning experience
如果我们伴随着经济或社会特权长大，能够获得教育、第二次机会、支持网络、家族财富，或者仅仅是你可以恢复的保证，你的大脑就会了解到失败是可以挺过去的。你能够把它视为一次学习经历
rather than a threat. And this creates a more secure mindset, one that supports experimentation and creativity and resilience. It's like that documentary, you know, to bring up Victoria Beckham twice in this episode. You know, someone DM'd me and she made a great point that, yes, she was brave to try. But her company did go bankrupt and she did have a multi-millionaire husband to support that. And that safety net is actually what secured her inevitable success, not just her attitude towards failure. It's easier to take those kinds of risks when you have security, food, warmth, and money.
而不是一种威胁。这就创造了一种更安全的心态，一种支持实验、创造力和韧性的心态。就像那部纪录片一样，你知道，在这期节目中两次提到维多利亚·贝克汉姆。你知道，有人给我私信，她提出了一个很好的观点，是的，她敢于尝试。但她的公司确实破产了，而且她确实有一个亿万富翁丈夫来支持这一点。而正是这种安全网确保了她不可避免的成功，而不仅仅是她对失败的态度。当你拥有安全、食物、温暖和金钱时，承担那种风险会更容易。
In contrast, when money is tight or opportunities are scarce, you know, failure isn't just emotional, as it is with everybody. It's also about survival. And it can trigger a deep sense of danger and scarcity that some people, you know, they just may never feel that. People who have less privilege often develop what Columbia University psychologists, They first labeled this in the 90s. It's called a prevention focus. So a prevention focus means that their motivation for doing well or for pursuing things
相比之下，当资金紧张或机会匮乏时，你知道，失败不仅仅是情绪上的，正如对每个人一样。这也关乎生存。它会引发一种深刻的危险感和匮乏感，有些人，你知道，可能永远不会有这种感觉。缺乏特权的人通常会培养出哥伦比亚大学心理学家所说的那种特质。他们在90年代首次将其命名。这被称为预防焦点。所以，预防焦点意味着他们做好事或追求事物的动机
centers on avoiding loss rather than seeking growth. It's not like they're less ambitious or less capable. It's not even that they're less likely to achieve what they want or be successful. It's just that for them, their motivation is different and the stakes are high. entire. If you have, in contrast, a promotion focus compared to a prevention focus, your motivation is, I love the idea of winning. I'm envisioning how good this is going to feel. I want a successful life. I want to challenge myself. It's less about I want to escape poverty. And it's less about I want to avoid bankrupting myself or my family and more about what can be an addition to your life.
集中在避免损失而不是寻求成长上。这并不是说他们野心较小或能力较差。甚至也不是说他们实现目标或成功的可能性较小。只是对他们而言，他们的动机不同，而且赌注很高。整个。相比之下，如果你拥有促进焦点而不是预防焦点，你的动机是：我喜欢获胜的想法。我在设想这会有多爽。我想要成功的生活。我想挑战自我。这较少关于我想摆脱贫困。这较少关于我想避免让自己或家人破产，而更多关于什么能成为你生活中的加分项。
So when we say don't be afraid to fail, we do need to acknowledge that that is much easier advice to follow when you have a safety net. And I just felt the need to say that because going forward, obviously I'm going to talk about how we can celebrate failures, big and small. But we do have to make that caveat that, you know, there is another part of this picture that you can't just ignore. So when we fear failure, whether because of context, attitude, psychology, upbringing, a few things happen. Firstly, I often find that the more I want something, the more I don't want to fail, the harder it actually becomes to act on that feeling or to achieve that dream because I am so scared of jinxing it that you know the pressure amounts to do and to act but with each step there is this constant back and forth, internally that's like, well, is this the exact right next step?
所以当我们说不要害怕失败时，我们确实需要承认，当你拥有安全网时，遵循这个建议要容易得多。我之所以觉得有必要这么说，是因为接下来，显然我会讨论我们如何庆祝大小失败。但我们必须加上这个前提，你知道的，这其中还有另一部分是不能忽视的。所以当我们害怕失败时，无论是由于背景、态度、心理、成长环境，都会发生几件事。首先，我经常发现，我越想要某样东西，越不想失败，就越难对那种感觉采取行动或实现那个梦想，因为我太害怕言灵反噬了，你知道，压力会不断积累去行动、去做，但每迈出一步，内心就会有一种不断的拉扯，像是在说，好吧，这真的是绝对正确的下一步吗？
Will I regret my next move? And so I don't end up doing anything. You've probably heard of this term, analysis paralysis. This is what this is describing. You're so invested in the outcome of a decision that you actually can't make the decision because the possibility of it being wrong paralyzes you, petrifies you. So instead of taking that chance, you just do nothing. and as a result, you get nowhere.
我会后悔我的下一步行动吗？所以我最后什么也没做。你可能听说过这个词：分析瘫痪。这就是这所描述的。你对一个决定的结果投入太多，以至于你实际上无法做出决定，因为结果错误的潜在可能让你瘫痪了，吓呆了。所以你没有抓住机会，而是什么都不做。结果，你哪儿也去不了。
We may label it as different things. You may call it self-sabotage, avoidance, procrastination, laziness. No, it all actually stems from wanting something really deeply. And it stems from that fear of failure. The second consequence is that you may still be able to act and make decisions, but you've kind of got like one foot in and one foot out. You kind of, we call it playing defensively. You hesitate before taking the leap.
我们可能会给它贴上不同的标签。你可能会称之为自我设障、回避、拖延、懒惰。不，这一切其实都源于内心深处对某物极度渴望。并且它源于对失败的恐惧。第二个后果是，你可能仍然能够采取行动并做出决定，但你有点像是一只脚在里面，一只脚在外面。有点像，我们称之为消极防守。你在飞跃之前犹豫不决。
And because you hesitate, that actually hurts you. It's no surprise that a lot of research on this has been done with elite student athletes or just elite athletes in general. In fact, one meta-analysis I found from 2021 found that in the last 10 years, over 45 studies on the fear of failure in rugby players, basketball players, sprinters, I don't know, water polo players all show that fearing failure is a significant predictor of poorer performance because it creates anxiety around what the next move will be. And it means that, again, people play defensively. It's almost like we fear failure to protect ourselves from failure, but it actually makes the chances of failure greater. It's all like an illusion, an illusion of control. The final cost of fear, failure is that we don't allow ourselves to experiment. Even if we can act on our desires,
正因为你犹豫了，这其实会伤害到你。难怪很多关于这方面的研究都是针对精英学生运动员或纯粹的精英运动员进行的。事实上，我发现的一项2021年的元分析发现，在过去的10年里，针对橄榄球运动员、篮球运动员、短跑运动员、我不知道、水球运动员的45多项关于失败恐惧的研究都表明，害怕失败是表现较差的重要预测因素，因为它围绕着下一步行动会是什么产生了焦虑。这意味着，再次说明，人们在消极防守。这几乎就像我们害怕失败是为了保护自己免受失败，但它实际上使失败的几率更大。这完全是一种幻觉，一种控制的幻觉。恐惧的最终代价，失败是我们不允许自己进行实验。即使我们可以根据自己的愿望采取行动，
and we do find success, we still remain quite rigid and quite inflexible. We don't try and use things. We don't take risks. We can develop this deep sense that at any moment this can all be taken away, even when we have success, even when we got an A, even when we got the job we wanted, we got the promotion, we got the deal. It doesn't feel. good enough because now we're imagining not having it and that fear still haunts us. I can personally say this has happened to me when my podcast first started gaining listeners, not to like break the fourth wall here, but when it did and it was very unexpected, I was just paralyzed by like, this can be taken away at any moment and I could still fail.
而且我们确实取得了成功，我们依然保持着相当死板和相当不灵活的状态。我们不尝试和利用事物。我们不承担风险。我们可以产生一种深刻的感觉：这一切随时都可能被拿走，即使我们取得了成功，即使我们得了A，即使我们得到了想要的工作，得到了晋升，得到了交易。这感觉并不。足够好，因为现在我们想象着失去它，而那种恐惧仍然萦绕在我们心头。我个人可以证明，当我的播客开始获得听众时，这种情况就发生在我身上，这不是要在这里打破第四面墙，但当它发生且非常出乎意料时，我只是被这样一种想法瘫痪了：这一切随时都可能被拿走，我还是会失败。
I could still like, this could all just go away. and it meant that I didn't try things and that I was so, like, I just felt like handcuffed to everything that I'd always done, like the first two years of the show, like, trying to make it exactly as it always was that I didn't like experiment. And it's probably only now that I've been like, okay, who cares? Like, I'm going to try new things. There's no point succeeding at something if I don't actually enjoy the process. This is the thing that all successful people know to be true and that I have learned from being around successful people, and having the privilege to be around successful people, you cannot win if you don't have some skin in the game. You will not find love if you never open the door to the possibility of being hurt.
我还是会像……这一切都可能烟消云散。这意味着我没有尝试新事物，而且我非常……就像，我感觉自己像被手铐铐住了一样，被我一直以来所做的一切束缚着，就像节目的头两年那样，试图让它变得和以前一模一样，以至于我没有去进行实验。可能直到现在我才想通，好吧，谁在乎呢？我要尝试新事物。如果我不能真正享受这个过程，成功就毫无意义。这是所有成功人士都知道的事实，也是我从与成功人士相处、并有幸与成功人士相处中学到的东西，如果你没有投入真金白银，你就不可能赢得胜利。如果你从来不打开可能受伤的门，你就永远不会找到爱。
You will never be considered at work if you're too scared to put your hand up and say, I want that. You will never be recognized for your art if you don't make it. And that means starting from a place that you may not be proud of and that may make you consider yourself a failure. You know those times when, like, you've heard a quote so many times before and then it just suddenly takes on like a whole deeper new meaning for you. That is this quote for me.
如果你太害怕举起手说“我想要那个”，你在工作中就永远不会被赏识。如果你不创作，你的艺术就永远不会被认可。这意味着要从一个你可能并不以此为傲、甚至可能让你觉得自己是个失败者的起点开始。你知道那些时刻，就像，你以前听过很多遍的一句名言，然后它突然对你产生了一种更深、全新意义的时刻。对我来说，这就是这句话。
Like you've got to have some skin in the game. That is like how I really am planning to live my life for the next couple of months or hopefully forever. You have to be prepared to fail and to maybe be hurt. Sixthestful people also know that you need to have enough equal. go to think you can do it, but not too much that you don't think setbacks say anything other than I have more to learn, or this isn't my time. You have to just be stupidly stubborn and delusional about your ideas. I read this fantastic excerpt from the book, The Anatomy of a Breakthrough by Adam Adler,
就像你必须投入真金白银一样。这就是我真正计划在未来几个月或希望永远这样生活的方式。你必须做好失败的准备，并可能受到伤害。成功人士也知道，你需要拥有足够的自我。去认为你能做到，但又不能多到让挫折除了“我还有更多东西要学”或“现在还不是我的时间”之外，不说明任何其他问题。你必须对自己的想法保持愚蠢的固执和妄想。我读过亚当·阿勒（Adam Adler）的书《突破的剖析》（The Anatomy of a Breakthrough）中一篇精彩的节选，
where he talks about how the perfect success to failure ratio is around 16%. So one in six times, 16% of the time, you will make errors or you will have to make an error or you will have to fail in order to find success. And he looks at these case studies or the researchers looked at these case studies of all these successful people, successful businesses, successful artists, and all of them kind of came back to this failure point, 16% of the time. One in six times they tried something. They objectively or subjectively, they failed. But once you allow that to be the case and you make room for that, that's when your progress actually skyrockets.
他在书中谈到完美的成功与失败比例大约是16%。也就是说，在六分之一的情况下，16%的时间里，你会犯错，或者你必须犯错，或者你必须经历失败才能找到成功。他研究了这些案例研究，或者研究人员研究了所有这些成功人士、成功企业、成功艺术家的案例研究，所有这些都某种程度上归结到这个失败点，占时间的16%。他们尝试某事有六分之一的机会。无论客观还是主观上，他们都失败了。但一旦你允许这种情况发生并为之腾出空间，那才是你的进度真正呈火箭式上升的时候。
That is the secret to success. Okay, we're going to talk about some of the other ways that you can reframe and fall in love with failure after this short break. Stay with us. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%, I break down the same.
这就是成功的秘密。好的，在短暂的休息之后，我们将讨论其他一些可以让你重新定义并爱上失败的方法。请继续收听。2%。这就是当旁边有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人所占的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析。
science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships. and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person.
关于心理坚韧、体能在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中构建适应力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，看透主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们弄错了。我们在世界上惊慌失措的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，
Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-P-O-P-Sent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at a podcast. I'm Sam Jette.
你最终会迎来一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的自己。收听《2%》。也就是在I-Hart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方搜索T-W-O-P-O-P-Sent。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在VMAs上双击小肯姆（Little Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什（George Bush）不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小肯姆到底有什么关系？嗯，你可以在《回顾》（Look Back at it）播客中找到答案。我是山姆·杰特（Sam Jette）。
And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now.
我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ（Alex English）。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一集与马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）的访谈，畅谈80年代的可卡因。申明一下，84对我来说意义重大，不只是因为可卡因。我随时都可以聊当天的可卡因，只是为了让你们知道。我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论可卡因的第二集了。所以我开始看出一条贯穿线了。我们现在也把艾滋病摆在桌面上。
Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests.
谢谢你把那句话说完。是的。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的一年之一。在iHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回顾》。欢迎来到我的新播客《艰难一课》（Learn the Hard Way），我是你的主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师凯尔·盖恩斯（Kear Gaines）。为了纪念心理健康意识月，我带来了我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与许多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。
I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine. Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch.
我说的是特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）。瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时，当我们在追求某样东西时，我们太过于沉迷于追逐，以至于我们没有意识到我们已经拥有了这件东西，而我们还在追逐它，并且我们不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们在看记分牌。
Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust.
生活变成了关于赢和输。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），因为你觉得作为一个好人很重要，当你身处地球时，还是你作为一个好人是因为你害怕？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对的。那是两个不同层面的信任。
I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd
我希望你真正地成为一个好人。加入我，凯尔·盖恩斯（Kear Gaines），在我的新播客《艰难一课》中，就疗愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和目标进行真正的对话。打开你免费的iHeartRadio应用。搜索“Learn the Hard Way”并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德
found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case.
发现自己成为了一场亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法庭听证会暴露了他故事中明显的矛盾之处。这引发了一场长达多年的法庭之战来证明真相。你曾两次篡改这份特定的检测报告，对吗？我篡改过一次检测。这动用了大批互联网侦探来破解这个案子。
I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Gregalespian and Michael Marincini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap.
我想让人们看到他们的纳税被用在了什么地方。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两名经历过同样事情的男士：格雷格·吉莱斯皮（Greg Gillespie）和迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Marincini）。我当时惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《受困之爱》（Love Trap）。
Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Okay, so I want to give you a few other ways you can allow yourself to fall in love with failure. We've been talking a lot about what successful people do differently and what that teaches us about the relationship we have between failure and thriving. And I want to cite one more
劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于要承担后果了。女士们先生们，马里科帕县的突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这还没完。在Iheart radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《受困之爱》播客。好的，我想给你提供另外几种方法，让你能够允许自己爱上失败。我们一直在讨论成功人士的不同做法，以及这给我们带来的关于失败与繁荣之间关系的启示。我想引用关于这个主题的另一个
study on this topic. It is one of my favorite studies of all time. And if you follow me on Instagram at that psychology podcast for a little plug, you most certainly will have heard of it. I talk about it there like probably more than I should. But it is a study by Angela Duckworth that found that more than anything else, more than IQ, even at times more than background and how you were raised, the thing that predicts success in people is grit. Grit, the ability to persevere even in tough times, the ability to fail and to push through despite difficulty. This is the thing that she found time and time again bridges the gap between raw talent or limited talent and actually achieving your goals and achieving your dreams.
研究。这是我最喜欢的历史研究之一。如果你在Instagram上关注我（打个小广告，账号是that psychology podcast），你肯定听说过它。我在那里谈论它的次数可能比我应该的还要多。但这是安吉拉·达克沃斯（Angela Duckworth）的一项研究，该研究发现，比其他任何事情都更能预测人们成功的是坚毅品质（grit），甚至有时比智商、背景和成长方式更重要。坚毅，即即使在艰难时期也能坚持不懈的能力，经历失败并在困难面前依然推进的能力。这是她一次又一次发现的连接原始才能或有限才能与真正实现目标、实现梦想的桥梁。
It's a tolerance for failure. It's the ability to grate your teeth and just say, I might have to suffer for this dream and I might have to be pained by this dream and by what happens, but I'm going to do it anyway. Anyways, and that's the superpower. Something to add on to this as well is that not only is failure just a part of the progress and process sometimes, it is, if nothing else, the most efficient way to get ahead. to fail forward.
这是一种对失败的容忍度。这是一种咬紧牙关说“我可能得为这个梦想受苦，我可能得因这个梦想以及发生的事情而感到痛苦，但我无论如何都要去做”的能力。无论如何，这就是超能力。另外需要补充的一点是，失败不仅有时是进步和过程的一部分，如果非要说的话，它是前进最高效的方式。
That's like the saying, right? To fail forward. You will never, and I truly believe this, you will never learn faster than you will learn from failing because the emotional resonance of it is going to mean the lesson is not forgotten. You know, they find this in experiments on learning in memory. People remember better when a negative experience was attached to a choice versus when they were slowly rewarded towards the right choice.
这就是那句名言，对吧？“向失败前行”（fail forward）。你永远不会，我坚信这一点，你从失败中学到的东西永远比其他任何方式都快，因为失败的情感共鸣意味着这个教训不会被遗忘。你知道，他们在关于学习和记忆的实验中发现了这一点。当负面体验与某个选择挂钩时，人们的记忆效果更好，这好过他们被缓慢引导至正确选择并获得奖励的情况。
I think it also means when you fail you get to close doors you'd otherwise just sit staring at and just sit and contemplate for longer than you needed to when the outcome was always going to be the same you just waited longer to get there personally I think this is especially the case with love I'm sure my friends sick of hearing me say this but I always say to them like if you really like someone don't agonize over whether they like you back or whatever. Like, ask them, make a move. Say, like, I want to date you or, like, I want to be committed or I want to see you. And you will get your answer really quick.
我认为这也意味着当你失败时，你得以关上那些你本会一直盯着看的门，并且在结果注定相同的情况下，你会比原本需要的时间更长地坐在那里沉思，你只是花了更长的时间才走到那一步。就我个人而言，我认为这在爱情中尤其如此。我确信我的朋友们已经厌烦听我这么说，但我总是对他们说：如果你真的喜欢某人，不要为他们是否也喜欢你而感到痛苦。去问他们，采取行动。说：“我想和你约会”或者“我想安定下来”或者“我想见你”。你会很快得到答案。
Either it's a yes or a no. And if it's a no, then you've just saved yourself, like, so much time that you otherwise would have spent worrying about being rejected or worrying about failing in this, like, relationship scenario. Failure also creates growth because, yes, it is a fast delivery system for lessons, but also because through challenge and sometimes through loss, like you gain resilience and you gain new skills. Whenever I fail, I always think to myself and I always think about bodybuilders, actually, really buff people and how they build muscle. They They build muscle by breaking their muscle down.
要么是，要么不是。如果不是，那你实际上就省下了很多时间，否则你本会把这些时间花在担心被拒绝或担心在这个恋爱剧本中失败上。失败也会促进成长，因为没错，它是传授经验的快速通道，但也是因为通过挑战，有时通过失去，你会获得韧性和新的技能。每当我失败时，我总是告诫自己，并且总会想到健美运动员，那些肌肉非常健硕的人，以及他们是如何塑造肌肉的。他们是通过撕裂肌肉来塑造肌肉的。
Intense exercise actually creates these tiny microscopic damage or tears to the muscle, which the body then fills in and rebuilds to make them stronger. I always think about this. You have to break muscle to build it back. Sometimes you have to experience the unpleasantness of failure to know what went wrong, to know why it probably wasn't the right time, and to come back and to do it better and to build the muscle. failure is like is such a gift in that way like the pain is never for nothing like there's always
高强度运动实际上会对肌肉造成这些微小的微观损伤或撕裂，然后身体会对其进行填补和重建，使其变得更强壮。我总是想到这一点。你必须破坏肌肉才能重建它。有时你必须经历失败的不愉快，才知道哪里出了问题，知道为什么它可能不是好时机，然后卷土重来，做得更好，并练就肌肉。从这个意义上说，失败简直就像是一份大礼，痛苦从来都不是白受的，因为总会
some kind of growth on the other side so when we take all of these like lessons and learnings from research and like from the lives of people we admire you start to really see that when you change your relationship to failure you do become untouchable because the emotional reaction you have to it will no longer slow you down in fact it will speed things up because it will feel you, it will motivate you, it will direct you. How I picture this for all of us is like encountering failure and like genuinely being like, oh my God, yes, and like celebrating it and being like, this is amazing. And maybe that's a bit far-fetched that we could have such a positive reaction to it. But I like to imagine, you know, not getting the grade, not getting the job, not getting
在另一面带来某种成长。因此，当我们吸收所有这些来自研究以及我们钦佩之人的生活的经验和教训时，你就会真正发现，当你改变与失败的关系时，你确实会变得无可匹敌，因为你对失败的情绪反应将不再拖慢你的脚步，事实上它会加快事情的进展，因为它会为你提供动力，激励你，指引你。我为我们所有人想象的画面是，遇到失败时，由衷地觉得，哦天哪，太棒了，并且庆祝它，觉得这太不可思议了。也许我们能对它产生如此积极的反应有点异想天开。但我喜欢想象，你知道的，没有拿到成绩，没有得到工作，没有达到
the time for your run, not getting the progress you wanted and being like, this is a gold mine for me. This is like a treasure of learnings that everyone who succeeded on their first go or everyone who didn't try, they don't get this. They don't get these lessons. Like these are just for me. These are just for the people who try and fail. No one else gets those. You know, I can't speak for you guys, but sometimes as well, nothing motivates me more than being told I can't do things or not being successful the first time around. having to prove it to myself or maybe to others.
跑步的目标，没有取得你想要的进展，然后觉得，这对金矿来说简直是我的宝藏。这就像是一笔学习财富，所有第一次尝试就成功的人，或者所有没有尝试过的人，他们都得不到这个。他们得不到这些教训。就像这些只属于我。这些只属于那些敢于尝试并经历失败的人。其他人是得不到的。你知道的，我不能替你们大家发言，但有时，没有什么比别人对我说我做不到，或者第一次没有成功更能激励我的了。我必须向自己证明，或者也许向其他人证明。
We know that this has a name. It's called the underdog effect or the rebellion theory. Your need to prove yourself or others or your failures wrong actually has such a deeply motivational power that can at times be stronger than just your own initial urge to want something. Like I have to prove this wrong. This rebellion effect is like whether it's spite, whether it's ego, whatever it is, whether it's pride, it drives you and it forces you to get back on the horse.
我们知道这有一个名字。它被称为底层效应或叛逆理论。你需要证明自己或他人或你的失败是错的，这种需求实际上具有如此深厚的动机力量，有时甚至会强过你想要某事物的纯粹最初冲动。就像我必须证明这是错的。这种叛逆效应，无论是出于赌气、出于自我、无论是什么，无论是出于自豪感，它都会驱使你并迫使你重整旗鼓。
So to finish this episode, I'm going to give you some rapid fire tips to kind of ritualize failure in your life and therefore fall in love with it, to practice it like you were to craft or a skill. Firstly, I'm going to challenge you to just start when you don't yet know whether things will be perfect. Start without all the information, whether it's an essay, an assignment, whether it's a for a job you don't quite know you're qualified for, whether it's asking someone on a date. This might be hard if you're a perfectionist, but the biggest hurdle, I think, we actually need
所以在结束本集之际，我要给你一些快节奏的建议，让你在生活中将失败仪式化，从而爱上它，像对待一门手艺或技能一样去练习它。首先，我要向你发出挑战：在事情还远谈不上完美时就开始行动。在没有掌握全部信息的情况下开始，无论是一篇论文、一项作业，还是一份你不太确定自己是否有资格胜任的工作，又或者是向某人约会。如果你是个完美主义者，这可能会很难，但我认为我们实际上需要克服的
to get over is the first hurdle. Whenever we want to do something, the first hurdle is the hardest of just being like, I'm going to act. I'm going to stop thinking about it and I'm going to do something, getting over that initial fear that stops the impulse. I like to use the five-minute principle. This basically says you can do a lot of things in five minutes and for five minutes. So whatever it is, why not just try for five minutes and see how you feel? Try and start to write that book. Just do five minutes of writing, five minutes of painting, five minutes of this job application, five minutes of the essay. And you'll actually notice that you end up having a lot of momentum and you know, how much you thought this was going to be difficult. You thought that this task was going to be hard
最大障碍就是第一道坎。每当我们想做某事时，第一道坎总是最艰难的，那就是对自己说：“我要行动了。我不再胡思乱想了，我要做点什么。”跨越那个阻止冲动的最初恐惧。我喜欢使用五分钟原则。这基本上是说，你可以在五分钟内以及用五分钟做很多事情。所以无论是什么，为什么不先尝试五分钟，看看你的感觉如何？尝试开始写那本书。只需写五分钟，画五分钟画，花五分钟填这份求职申请，写五分钟论文。你会发现你最终会产生很大的动力，而且你知道的，你之前觉得这会有多困难。你曾以为这项任务会很艰难
or burdensome. It's actually not. And you actually find a lot of joy in doing it. And it probably felt like a lot of work. But, you know, the work was actually just what your mind has created to stop you from trying. The first, like the five minute principle is so fantastic for getting over like the initial stagnation or the initial, the initial fears that kind of hold you back from doing. I also say once a month, be a beginner. just do something that you've never done before and be terrible at it. I was doing this a lot last year with like pottery. I was doing, I don't know what I was thinking, but I was in this like intermediate class and I was terrible.
或是个负担。其实不然。你实际上在其中找到了很多乐趣。它可能感觉像是一项繁重的工作。但你知道的，这项工作实际上只是你的大脑为了阻止你尝试而凭空制造出来的。最初的，比如五分钟原则，对于克服最初的停滞不前或最初的、阻碍你行动的最初恐惧，简直太棒了。我还建议每个月当一次初学者。只需做一件你从未做过的事，并且做得一塌糊涂。去年我经常这样做，比如陶艺。我当时在做，我不知道自己在想什么，但我当时在一个中级班里，而且我做得烂极了。
I also was the person who had the most fun. Like I can objectively say I was having the most fun because I didn't care. Like I didn't care if this was like, it's just sometimes the best feeling being the worst at something because the only way you can go is up. and you just get to like hang out in this place of experimentation and you're going to hang out in this place of just being completely excited by what there is to learn. I'd also ask you to be reflective and just to look back at times that you've failed in the past to see how much wiser you have become because of it.
我同时也是那个玩得最开心的人。我可以客观地说，我当时玩得最开心，因为我根本不在乎。我才不在乎这算什么，当一个领域的吊车尾有时真的是最棒的感觉，因为你唯一能去的地方就是向上。你只需在这个充满实验的地方闲逛，在这个因将要学到的东西而感到彻底兴奋的地方闲逛。我还想请你进行反思，回顾一下你过去失败的经历，看看由于这些经历，你变得多么明智。
You know, some of the ways I've failed is like I didn't, I've talked about this before. Like, you know, I applied for all these internships and jobs when I was first living university. and I didn't get like a single one. And I had to come back the year afterwards and apply again. And, you know, luckily I got one offer. That first year felt like a failure. I came back and I was doing better the second time. At least, you know, I had a job by that stage as well.
你知道的，我经历过的一些失败就像我没有，我以前谈过这个。比如，当我刚离开大学时，我申请了所有这些实习和工作。结果一个都没拿到。我不得不第二年回来重新申请。而且，幸运的是我得到了一个Offer。第一年感觉就像是一场失败。第二年我卷土重来，表现得更好。至少，你知道的，到了那个阶段我也有一份工作了。
Like so many failures that it's almost hard for me to even call them out as failures because they've just been integrated into my life as lessons. like obviously I did my half marathon a couple of weeks ago right and there was a lot of failure leading up to that runs that I just didn't finish runs that would like I walked that just felt awful it's hard for me to even see those as failures because like they had to happen I had to get them out of the way to get to the good stuff I'd also say try and have a process for what you will do or give to yourself after you have failed almost just make it like a date night, like the day after you realize, like, oh my God, maybe I have to
经历了如此多的失败，以至于我甚至很难将其称之为失败，因为它们已经作为经验教训融入了我的生活。显然，我几周前完成了我的半程马拉松，对吧？在那之前有很多失败，比如根本跑不完的跑步，比如我不得不步行、感觉糟糕透顶的跑步。我甚至很难将这些视为失败，因为它们必须发生。我必须把它们抛诸脑后，才能迎接美好的事物。我还想说，试着为你失败后要做的事或给予自己的奖励制定一个流程，几乎就像是一场约会之夜，就在你意识到诸如“天哪，也许我得
quit this thing. Maybe this will just not work. Maybe this is a so-called failure. Reward yourself. Go take yourself out for dinner, get a glass of wine, get some pasta, bring your journal, and just write down everything that you learned from that. Everything that this moment has taught you that is going to really help you in the future. And I also, want you to be very diligent and honest with yourself about what was within your control during this situation and what was outside of your control, what you can change, what you are responsible for and what you are not. Now, in absorbing failure, that doesn't mean that we need to just be like, well, this was all my fault. I just need to work harder. I just didn't have it in me this time.
放弃这件事了。也许这根本行不通。也许这算不上什么所谓的失败”之后的第二天。犒劳一下自己。带自己出去吃顿晚饭，喝杯葡萄酒，吃点意大利面，带上你的日记，写下你从中学到的一切。写下这个时刻教给你的一切，这些将在未来真正帮助到你。而且我还希望你对自己非常勤勉和诚实，弄清楚在这场遭遇中什么是你能控制的，什么是你无法控制的，什么你可以改变，什么是你要负责的，什么不是。现在，包容失败并不意味着我们只需要表现得好像：“好吧，这全怪我自己。我只是需要更努力。我这次就是没有这块料。”
sometimes it is just timing. Sometimes it is just the situation and it is just context and it is just that someone worked harder than you or someone got to the idea before you or someone had more privilege than you. It's important to acknowledge those things so that you don't take the entire burden of a misstep or a missed opportunity onto yourself, but also realize and take what can be changed and make sure that that is the more important thing. The most important thing is what you choose to do with the circumstances and also what you can learn from the previous situations and apply.
有时这只是时机问题。有时这只是局势和背景问题，只是有人比你更努力，或者有人比你更早想出这个点子，或者有人比你拥有更多的特权。承认这些事情很重要，这样你就不会把失误或错失良机的全部负担独自扛在肩上，但同时也要意识到并抓住那些可以改变的东西，确保这才是更重要的事情。最重要的是你选择如何对待当前的境况，以及你能从以前的情况中学到什么并加以应用。
So acknowledge it, but don't linger for too long and just take the lessons. And remember what I said before. Those lessons are something that the person who tries, the person who just like succeeds in their first try, sorry, does not get, this is like, you are the only one who gets these lessons. I'd also say just try and get more comfortable with sharing failures. I'm so lucky I have friends where we do this all the time. We talk very openly about the things that didn't go right. And that's honestly just so reassuring sometimes and just so comforting to be like, okay, someone else has been here. And just remember that if you are going to fail,
所以要承认它，但不要纠缠太久，只需汲取教训。并记住我之前说过的话。这些教训是那些尝试的人、抱歉，那些第一次尝试就成功的人所无法得到的，这就像，你是唯一一个获得这些教训的人。我还想说，试着对分享失败感到更自在。我很幸运，我有这样的朋友，我们经常这样做。我们非常坦诚地谈论那些进展不顺利的事情。老实说，有时这真的非常令人安心，让人觉得：“好吧，别人也经历过这个。”只需记住，如果你注定要失败，
the best time to do it is now. Especially if you're, in your 20s, I know most of us are, it is the psychology of your 20s after all. Like, this is the failure decade. I really don't think that you're actually even an adult until like 30. This is just like your trial period, right? This is like the probation period for your job. This is the probation period for your adult life. This is just where nothing, like you can just try and fail and just like completely maybe even make it full of yourself, hopefully not, but like, just completely be a beginner and it won't, it won't do anything other than make things better in the future because you have learned. And will make you a more empathetic person, will make you a
现在就是最好的时机。特别是如果你正处于20多岁，我知道我们大多数人都是，这毕竟是20多岁的心理学。就像，这是失败的十年。我真的不认为你在30岁之前真正算是个成年人。这只是你的试用期，对吧？这就像是你工作的实习期。这就像是你成年生活的实习期。这就是你可以无所顾忌、你可以尝试并失败、甚至可能彻底把事情搞砸（希望不要）的阶段，但无论如何，这除了让未来变得更好之外不会产生任何其他作用，因为你已经从中吸取了教训。而且这会让你成为一个更有同理心的人，一个
wiser person, will probably make you a more successful person rather than if you just sat and waited for everything to be perfect without ever actually learning a lesson from your mistakes. I will also say a quote, a final quote that has been resonating with me when we talk about failure, when we talk about having big dreams for ourselves, which I really hope you do. I hope you have big dreams for yourself is a quote from The Alchemist. I recently reread that book. It's one of my favorite books. I've read it so many times and it felt like a great time to reread it.
更明智的人，可能还会让你成为一个更成功的人，而不是那种只坐在那里等待一切完美却从未从错误中真正吸取教训的人。我还要分享一句名言，当我门谈论失败、谈论为自己怀揣宏伟梦想时（我真心希望你们有，我希望你们为自己怀揣宏伟梦想），这句名言最近一直与我产生共鸣，它出自《炼金术士》。我最近重读了那本书。它是我最喜欢的书之一。我已经读过很多次了，我觉得现在是重读它的绝佳时机。
And in the book, there's this very famous quote. When you have a dream, the whole universe conspires to make it come true. when you really want something, forces beyond you will conspire to make it happen. I don't know if that's true, to be honest, but I've felt it. I've felt what I think is a version of it. And I think it's something to really hold on to that wanting something and acting on it is never not going to be rewarded in some way or another. People love to see people who are working hard.
书中有一句非常著名的名言。当你拥有梦想时，整个宇宙都会合力助你实现。当你真正渴望某事时，超越你自身的力量会合力让它发生。说实话，我不知道这是否是真的，但我感受过。我感受过我认为是其中一种版本的体验。我认为这真的是一件值得坚守的事，那就是渴望某事并采取行动，永远都会以这样或那样的方式获得回报。人们喜欢看到努力奋斗的人。
People love to be inspired and motivated by people who go after their dreams. that's you. That's going to be your situation. Those can be your circumstances where the universe, God, the source, whatever it is, just the powers that be conspiring in your favor because you have put, you know, had some skin in the game. You've put yourself on the line and said, like, I'm willing to sacrifice and learn for what I want. So I think that is all we have time for. You guys know I've been doing this thing where if you've made it this far on the episode, hello. welcome. Thank you for listening. I've been asking people to leave stories or leave something in the comments that, you know, it's just for the people who've made it to this point. And today I really want to learn from
人们喜欢被那些追逐梦想的人所启发和激励。那个人就是你。那将是你的处境。那些可以成为你的境遇，宇宙、上帝、源头、无论它是什么，只是那些冥冥中的力量都在对你有利的方向上合力，因为你已经（你知道的）投入了真金白银。你将自己置于险境并说道：“我愿意为我想要的东西做出牺牲和学习。”我想这就是我们所有的全部时间了。你们知道我一直在做这样一件事：如果你能坚持收听这集节目到这里，你好，欢迎。谢谢你收听。我一直在要求大家在评论区留下故事或留下一些内容，你知道的，这只属于那些坚持到这一刻的人。今天我真的想向
your failures. What has been the biggest failure in your 20s? I want you to share if you feel comfortable the details of it below or you can be vague about it just so that we can learn from each other and also so that we can feel that this is, and normalize, that this is important. Particularly if maybe you're in your later 20s or even not in your 20s at all, what was something that you failed at in your early 20s that you're glad that you did? I really want to, I really want to know, I want to be able to learn from that, make it feel more normal and just like a completely natural part of growth. But I appreciate you listening as far as you have.
你的失败学习。你在20多岁时经历的最大失败是什么？如果你觉得可以的话，我希望你在下方分享细节，或者你可以对此轻描淡写，这样我们就可以互相学习，同时也让我们觉得这很重要，并将其常规化。特别是如果你可能正处于20多岁的尾巴，或者根本不在20多岁，你在20多岁出头时经历过什么失败但现在却为此感到庆幸？我真的很想知道，我希望能够从中学习，让它感觉更正常，感觉就像是成长中完全自然的一部分。不过我很感谢你能收听这么久。
If you are not already, make sure you are following us wherever you are listening, to the show right now on Spotify, on Apple Podcasts, on the IHeart radio app. We have December guest month coming up in a couple of weeks, no, in like a month, not a couple of weeks, several weeks. And I want you to be around for that because, oh my gosh, we have some insane guests this year. I just finished recording with one of them earlier and the conversation went for over two hours.
如果你还没关注的话，请确保你在你现在收听节目的任何地方关注我们，无论是在Spotify、苹果播客还是IHeart电台应用上。几周后，不，大约在一个月后，不是几周，是几个星期后，我们将迎来12月份的嘉宾月。我希望你能到场，因为，天哪，我们今年有一些疯狂的嘉宾。我刚刚和其中一位录完音，那段对话持续了两个多小时。
I don't know how I'm going to cut it down, but make sure that you are around for that exciting chapter. each year I love doing our guest series. So I can't wait for you guys to hear it. And that you're following us on Instagram as well at That Psychology Podcast. We also have a YouTube and we have an Instagram. No, I already said that. We have a YouTube and we have a substact.
我不知道该怎么剪辑，但请确保你不要错过那个激动人心的篇章。每年我都喜欢做我们的嘉宾系列节目。所以我迫不及待地想让你们听到。并且也请在Instagram上关注我们@That Psychology Podcast。我们还有一个YouTube和一个Instagram。不，我刚才已经说过了。我们有一个YouTube和一个Substack。
If you want the transcript to the episodes, including this episode right here, you can follow us there. It's obviously completely free. But until next time, stay safe, be kind. Be gentle to yourself. Embrace, celebrate fall in love with. failure and we will talk very very soon. Hey, what's good, y'all?
如果你想要包括本集在内的节目文字稿，你可以在那里关注我们。这显然是完全免费的。但直到下一次，保重，保持善良。对自己温柔一点。拥抱、庆祝并爱上失败。我们很快就会再聊。嘿，最近怎么样，各位？
You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Keer Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you're not to be played with.
你正在收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯（Keer Games）带来的《The Hardway》。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都极其不安全的坦诚对话，但你是在与一位懂行的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人带着盔甲生活？它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。
And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard. Broadway on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones.
仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你就必须这么做。在IHeart电台应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听Learn the Hardway。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。你在这个特定的测试上造假了两次甚至更多，对吗？我只在测试上造了一次假。
It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Ranini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences.
这需要一大群互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士：格雷格·吉莱斯皮（Greg Gillespie）和迈克尔·拉尼尼（Michael Ranini）。我的脑子彻底炸了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。
Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%.
在IHeart电台应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。2%。这就是当电梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养心理韧性、健康和韧性的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你最终会成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的。收听《2%》。
That's TWO percent on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
这就是在IHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听的TWO percent。当一群女性发现她们都与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓，我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友们。收听《The Girlfriends: Trust me, babe》，在IHeart电台应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方。
This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这是一个IHeart播客。保证由真人制作。本集暂无评论。点击文字稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。